how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder and we have some
insane spider-man 3 mcu news today
if it wasn't already crazy enough with
jamie foxx's electro returning
for spider-man 3 in a different universe
things are now getting even crazier than
before and everything is sort of coming
together now in a very
epic way it has now been officially
confirmed
that benedict cumberbatch is joining the
cast for
spider-man 3. that means in spider-man 3
doctor strange is going to be helping
out peter parker this report comes from
thehollywoodreporter.com and it reads as
follows
the good and strange doctor has been
caught in the spider's web
benedict cumberbatch is putting on the
cloak of levitation and will reprise
marvel's supernatural hero doctor
strange for the latest spider-man
movie installment starring tom holland
and being made by marvel studios and
sony pictures
the move puts cumberbatch in the mentor
role that was previously occupied by
robert downey jr who played tony stark
iron man and spider-man homecoming and
by samuel jackson
in spider-man far from home and they go
on to say that this gives peter parker a
father figure and gives the movie extra
star power
while also tying them to the greater
marvel cinematic universe so this pretty
much confirms that doctor strange is
going to bring the multiverse to
spider-man 3.
we've already expected it with the
confirmation that elektro jaime fox's
electro is going
to be in spider-man 3 and the rumors
going around that kirsten dunst and
others from different
universes not in the mcu are going to be
reprising their roles as well
and now we have a very clear answer of
just how this is all happening it's
going to be doctor strange that brings
everybody into spider-man 3. and as far
as we're concerned this is going to be
the first movie where the multiverse is
really opened up in one division they're
going to sort of explore this with her
creating alternate realities but it's
very apparent now that it's
really going to open up and be explored
and go into chaos in spider-man 3 and
this will lead us to doctor strange in
the multiverse of
madness it looks like spider-man 3 is
what's going to throw the multiverse
into madness
when we end spider-man 3 things are most
likely going to be very
very crazy and that's going to lead us
into doctor strange 2 where doctor
strange has to fix the multiverse that
was thrown into madness in spider-man 3.
now this really opens up endless
possibilities for spider-man 3 and it
definitely opens up the possibility for
us to see
tom holland spider-man toby maguire
spider-man and
andrew garfield spider-man all in one
movie
we've been expecting this for a while
but now that the good doctor has joined
spider-man 3
chances of this happening have just
increased exponentially
so doctor strange is confirmed to be in
spider-man 3
what do you hope happens in spider-man 3
now that doctor strange is in the movie
let me know what crazy insane things you
would like to see
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a loki
funko pop for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof